[Music]  you're welcome the path of life brings  us any trouble pain Vinny's talk sadness  humiliation pop happy Spa will rebuild  your DNA better than ever a better you  the best you can be  that's what I want how do you feel happy  [Music]  [Music]  no no it's fine  I woke up in a spa to work and came home  I woke up grave and then I walked for  six hours to find whatever the [ __ ] you  are  now there's two Me's but there's one  life so what do you suggest we do  maybe he has a brain tumor  inoperable IO he's better than me in  everything with work with Kate  are you seriously jealous of you  I know karate not unless you learned it  since yesterday morning you don't  do you know place this house of Gardens  got you  how can you be sure that you are you  your monster my dr. Jekyll dr. Jekyll  was the same one you mean mr. Hyde you  should pick up a book sometime  [Music]  [Music]